حسنًا ، بريانا ، كان من المفترض أن تصل الرحلة إلى
هنا في مطار ريغان الوطني في
وقت متأخر من الليلة الماضية بدلاً من ذلك ، اضطر الطاقم إلى
قلب الطائرة
للعودة إلى مطار أتلانتا الدولي
بعد 47 دقيقة
فقط من المغادرة ، هذه رحلة دلتا رقم
2281 وإليكم ما أبلغ الطاقم
لحركة الطيران  السيطرة
بعد أن اصطدمت تلك الطيور ،
تسلق واحد أربعة عشر ألفًا من دلتا
2281 فقط كان هناك ضربة طائر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى
] ومغادرة دلتا 2281 نعم
علينا العودة إلى الوراء ، لدينا
زجاج أمامي متصدع
سنقوم به  أعلن حالة
طوارئ واه
إلى أتلانتا دلتا 2021 14000 100
رطل من الوقود على متن الطائرة ،
نعم سنكون قادرين على الهبوط آه الآن
من النمط الذي يتم إعداده يا شباب ،
أريدك أن تنظر إلى الصور هنا
الآن هذه  هو ما اصطدم به الطائر على ما
يبدو الزجاج الأمامي لهذه الرحلة
بطائرة إيرباص A320
وبطريقة جيدة ، لأنه
جزء قوي جدًا من الطائرة ، يحتوي a320
على زجاج
أمامي مكون من ثلاث طبقات من
الزجاج المقوى ب  مقاومة الصواعق لتحمل الطيور ،
إنها قطعة قوية جدًا
من المعدات للطائرة ،
لذلك كان هناك صدع يقول الطاقم
على الرغم من أنه ليس كل هذه الصفقة الكبيرة ،
لا يبدو
أن الطاقم أو الركاب كانوا في
خطر كبير جدًا  أنت تعلم أن FAA
تقول أن هناك حوالي 15000 ضربة للطيور
في عام نموذجي وحوالي خمسة
بالمائة فقط من هذه الضربات
تؤدي إلى أضرار جسيمة
للطائرة